Let's multiply 4 times 2,012.
Actually, let's make it
a little bit simpler.
Let's multiply 4 times
201 just to simplify
things a little bit.
So 4 times 201.
So as we've seen
in previous videos,
I like to write the
larger number on top.
This is just one of
many ways of tackling
a calculation like this.
I'll write the 201.
And then I'll write
the 4 right below it,
and I'll write it right
below the ones place.
And so I have 201 times 4.
Now, just like we did when
we were multiplying a one
digit times a two digit, we do
essentially the same process.
We first multiply 4 times the 1.
Well, 4 times 1 we
know is equal to 4.
So we put a 4 right over
there in the ones place.
Then we can multiply
our 4 times the digit
that we have in the tens place.
In this case, we have
a 0 in the tens place.
So 4 times 0, well,
that's just 0.
4 times 0 is 0.
We put the 0 in the tens
place right over here.
And then last, we have 4
times this 2 right over here.
And so 4 times 2 is equal to 8.
And we put the 8
right over here.
And we get our answer-- 804.
Now, why did this work?
Well, remember,
when we multiplied
4 times 1, that was
literally just 4.
And we've got that
4 right over here.
When we multiply 4
times 0, that's 0 tens.
So we've got 0 tens
right over here.
And when we multiplied 4 times
2, this was actually a 200.
It's in the hundreds place.
So 4 times 200 is 800.
So what we're essentially
doing by writing it
in the right place is
we're saying, 4 times 201,
that's the same thing
as 4 times 200, which
is 800, plus 4
times 0 tens, which
is 0 tens, plus 4
times 1, which is 4.
So 800 plus 0 plus 4 is 804.